uh today's environment um in both the
public and private markets uh could be
described as uh
frothy if i was to be kind um and
there's all kinds of uh
kind of craziness and people are kind of
scratching their head as to what's going
on
you've got experience with public and
private companies
how do you think about you know when a
private company should go public when
they should stay private when they
should stay family owned first take on
investors like
just how do you think about navigating
what i'll call the capital markets and
kind of governance of public and private
companies is there some framework that
you would use
to think through that if you were an
executive today
both have pros and cons i'm ambivalent
about the answer to that i
i think having a public company is a
great tool with stock options to be able
to attract and retain
and be able to punch above your weight
if you've got a growth company
that's a huge advantage uh by the same
token
uh when they're quarterly earnings
can be a terrible um tight
noose around your neck and and uh when
you really have to make some longer term
investments and weight
in an environment that historically had
been maximized shareholder return
and with lots of opportunity as the
private equity buyout funds that are
looking for act or activist shareholders
that are looking for that opportunity
can step in so you have the issue of
control
so on the one hand there are tremendous
advantages of public ownership in my
view
and by the same token there are some
disadvantages
uh if i were to do it again
if i could have and i had to sell the
business in order to equitize my
father's
uh holdings and and uh and not have the
company sold
uh we didn't need a lot of capital
uh i would have invented phantom stock
options to replicate those of a public
company and i would have stayed private
yeah and it's really interesting i think
today to when
um the equation almost changes or the
evaluation
uh when the public markets will just
be so disjointed it seems like from kind
of traditional multiples and things like
that
uh it's almost as if the financial
incentive becomes greater
to for people to get into the public
market but i recently had a gentleman on
he's been the
ceo of a company for uh it's publicly
traded for 22 years
and what he said to me was uh once
you're in the public markets it's really
hard to go back
you can go back but you're pretty much a
public company and so you have to
understand it's not just about the
short-term decision-making
you know you're completely changing the
way that you're going to govern this
business and kind of make decisions
and do you want to sign up for that or
not in my case
and i broke the 35 years into six
distinct eras
the first five years we were magical
we made little mistakes we moved from
from success to success the second five
years once we were publicly owned
company
that success became a terrible
impediment
to future success we were growing the
first five years at 50
compounded i basically changed the
mission and objectives now as a public
company
to try to maintain that frothy price we
were trading at 60 70 times earnings
we were back in the late 60s again
most food service franchising businesses
were akin to
what you see in high-tech businesses
today in terms of the darling of wall
street
lost my way changed the mission and
tried to maintain an unrealistic
objective in terms of
maintaining share price and almost drove
the company
off a cliff that's when i learned the
importance of strategy
and how important it is if you're aiming
at the wrong target
uh the kind of cataclysmic result that
that
can create and how is the leader you can
take a whole team
and franchisees and everybody along with
you a lesson i never forgot and implied
it in the next
four eras five years each never looked
back again
but that is the seduction of a public
ownership
you know it was hard to put a a a a
a wise head on a 30 year old body that
had enjoyed an immense amount of success
it was a real problem i got fired
um had to talk my way back in we had
realized the error of our ways
and i said give me another quarter and
the board luckily did and but we had to
learn a lesson it was a tough
tough lesson a tough five years